have you always lived broadway because
then you're always all about i grew up
it's all broadway and i've always wanted
to do
this record yeah it for me it has been
the most and i know you've had these
kinds of records that feel the most
vocally exciting and the most
vocally expansive especially because as
artists sometimes if we get pegged with
one sound
100 that's why i love christmas albums
and nobody says yeah yeah okay nobody
cries nobody fusses nobody wants yeah
yeah yeah that's classic so i've always
wanted to do this because i grew up
doing theater
i grew up you know even in community
theater and high school and college
um all throughout and always really
wanted to get back to it super thankful
for the success i had as a musician
but also thankful that that success has
let me enter into then the theater
community at a place because you came
and saw me years ago like yes
i did and you were freaking awesome and
i've always wanted to i'm i'm a nerd for
broadway too i don't
know musical theater and so i i am
envious of this whole project
um and i was envious and just so elated
for you as well
you shine so bright it's so good it's
like it holds a place in your heart and
it really i think informs it's a hard
thing to do
too broadway is hard like it's a big
schedule it's an in yes
if you can nail that you're amazing it's
a big schedule but
it's just so enriching and and so worth
it and i think you know the music itself
just as you're saying
is it's so informative as an artist and
i know you get this too as a performer
you know you learn about what it is to
be a character in a song you learn about
what it is to embody
that it's not that far from country to
me like country music is all
storytelling
all stories yeah that's why whenever but
yeah they said you were doing the album
i was like well it's like more
storytelling obvious yeah you got a big
leap
yeah yep i'm still here just waiting for
you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever